good evening and welcome to the
performance governance
and audit committee meeting on thursday
the 10th
of june 2021 my name is councillor
jeanette stiltz
and i am the committee chairman before
we commence the business of the meeting
there are a few
house cook keeping rules issues to run
through
members the set up for the meeting has
been designed to mitigate for covid
therefore i can uh can i ask all present
to work to the protocols agreed at
council on the 29th of april 2021
in the interest of member safety
we are streaming this meeting live as
well as recording
and by being present in the meeting you
are giving your consent
to being recorded members and officers
during
each item please put your hand up we
have actually given you paddles because
the villa stability is not
brilliant from up here with the the
screen so if you can wave your paddle in
the air would be lovely
and then i will invite you to speak when
invited to speak please remove your mask
put on your visor
turn on your microphone phone and speak
clearly
please reference a page or paragraph
number
when referring to the agenda papers keep
your
contributions as clear and concise as
possible and ensure your microphones
remain
off when not speaking finally can i draw
your attention to the notices on the
agendas
papers regarding the different levels
within the chamber
and advise that the fire exit door is
behind
this top table i would also like to
welcome councillor stevens to this
first meeting of pgna and i believe this
is your
first meeting in chamber your second
meeting in chamber lovely
apologies for absence may i have
apologies for absence burner
yes chairman we've received apologies
for absence from councillors boyce
sorry voice and cancer heard
and we have cancer beal substitution for
counselor heard this evening
thank you thank you burner item two on
the agenda
it is recommended that the minutes of
the meeting held on the 25th
of march found on pages 5 to 10 are
approved as a true and
accurate record so i so move do i have a
seconder
council of i'm having a second those
minutes thank you
i give you pages five
six seven
eight nine
ten are you happy
to vote those by ascent
thank you oh councillor edwards
yesterday
thank you councillor edwards and the
same with councillor stevens
if everyone that was at the last meeting
is happy with them we will move on
item three on the agenda declarations of
interest to disclose the
existence and nature of any disclosable
pecuniary
interests other pecuniary interests or
non-pecuniary
interest relating to items of business
on the agenda
having regard to paragraph six to eight
inclusives of the code of conduct
for members members are reminded that
they also required to disclose
any such interest as soon as they become
aware
should the need arise throughout the
meeting do i have
any declarations of interest
i have none
thank you chad just any as a member of
essex county council
any item pertaining thank you thank you
councillor fleming
there is no other declarations of
interest i will move on to item
4 public participation i can advise that
we have received a submission from a
member of
the public mr tony fitoc in respect
of agenda item 5 quarterly risk report
and i will read this out following the
officer's presentation on item
five so agenda item five
can be found on pages 11 to 18 and i
call on mr dobson to present this item
thank you chairman
this is quarter four report of of
corporate risk
covering january to march 2021
the covering report in section 3.1.1
highlights the risks that have changed
in direction since quarter 3
and there is one risk recommended for
closure
there are two risks that have seen a
decrease in score
r9 failure to have coordinated approach
to supporting edward investment and
maximizing business rates growth
and our 30 may 2021 elections during the
covid campaign covered pandemic
risk to successfully deliver there are
also
three risks that have seen an increase
in score
r10 a failure to develop jobs to support
the growing population
and that reflects um the
kovid 19 still remains um the dominant
force on the on the economic landscape
and whilst the full impact and
implications of the pandemic and related
restrictions continue to be unknown
it's difficult for us to be clear about
being
able to create those jobs hence the the
increase in risk related to it
r7 the failure to maintain a five-year
supply of housing land
the odp review was approved by council
in march
2021 and that has been triggered by the
failure to maintain a
five-year housing land supply and whilst
further mitigation is being put in place
the the risk has come to realization
hence the
the increase
also increased r29 failure to the risk
of failure to deliver services as a
result of covid19
and this risk was increased because of
the potential for fatigue among officers
after
maintaining services through
the over a year now of
working in in pandemic conditions and
including two
national lockdowns whilst it hasn't had
a great impact on services
or in service delivering the capacity of
officers
it is an increased risk the longer that
the conditions go on
there's one risk that is recommended for
potential closure
and that's r13 failure to manage the
impact of organizational
change the corporate plan has now been
updated
resource reviews undertaken um an
additional
posts there was some additional funding
for posts in the the february
budget um and i think the the
organization that that risk was relating
to
the transformation i think the the
organization has
really come through that that that
process now whilst we have future
challenges
the um it was felt that the
organizational change had been managed
operationally we continue to regularly
review and mitigate corporate risk in
line with the risk management strategy
and this report is presented to
committee for oversight of this period
in time
thank you chairman thank you
before i go to uh members questions
i will move the recommendations and the
recommendations are one that the member
members review the corporate risk
register in appendix one
and provide comment and feedback for
consideration
two that members are assured through
this review that a
corporate risk is being managed
effectively
and little three that members challenge
risk where the committee feels that the
council's corporate goals
may not be achieved do i have a seconder
yeah i had to say thank you councillor
jarvis
um councillor nan you had your paddle
right yes sorry chairman can you deal
with the
public participation in public
submission sorry councillor now
i have two questions from the members of
the public which i
will now read out so page 15 r7
failure to maintain a five-year land
supply
and the question is from information
publicly
available it would appear that the
supply of land is not the issue
it is the supply of land to the
successful developers
identified within the ldp they are not
developing within the time frame
required to maintain
a five-year supply therefore what
lessons have been learned
and what can be done to mitigate the
risk of it repeating itself in the
future
i.e what can be done to ensure
developers develop prior to being
for one of a better word selected
if there is doubt should they be
selected
so do you want to answer that one or do
you want me to read the second one out
please
okay page 16
r5 failure to deliver and the required
infrastructure to put support
requirements
arising from the ldp it is fully
understood
from the majority of infrastructure to
be delivered is within the remit of ecc
rather than malden district council but
the assumptions
and details within the ldp are critical
to the delivery of
the required infrastructure one key
assumption was that an aging population
in burnham would mitigate
education expansion needs this it would
appear
has been proven wrong why perhaps it's
because the original
analysis was flawed perhaps the
aging population is downsizing out of
the district
perhaps essex county council models are
flawed
if it is to continue the essex county
council or to use
excuses capacities within district
then this needs to be understood and
reflected within the locations chosen
for the five-year land supply
the district has a negative secondary
education
plan when s southwood and ferris is
excluded this means that children in the
areas outside of main settlements have
no priority
catchment how is this influenced by
malden district council are there formal
mechanisms
in place to raise concerns how are they
escalated if unheeded how also is
infrastructure needed
influenced by essex county council home
to schools
transport policy requiring a strict
distance preference protocol
this influences natural historic
preference
even if there is no prospect of a place
at the nearest two schools therefore
increasing risk of out of planning
area placement i would suggest that
unless clear reasons and influences are
identified
it's not possible to mitigate future
risk
it is important to understand
interactions in dealing to the
facilitate
better decisions making and thus reduce
risk and improve delivery
thank you mr dobson
thank you chairman in response to to
question when i'd say um the local
development plan
2014 to 2029
set a 15-year development plan for the
molden district
although it wasn't adopted until july
2017.
the evidence used to underpin that plan
was largely prepared in the first five
years of the 2010s
when the concept of the five-year
housing land supply was very new in
national planning policy
being introduced by government in 2012.
in designing the approach of our ldp
review the council will be considering
drawing on the latest guidance from the
government in terms of determining how
to evaluate the suitability of sites
as well as drawing on our own practice
and the practice of other local planning
authorities around the country
national planning policy now stipulates
that ten percent of all allocated
housing growth must go on smaller sites
of under one hectare which will provide
greater choice in housing site size and
help to support smaller house builders
to bring housing forward
we've also undertaken a call for sites
that closed on the the 7th of june 2021
so we can now also start appraising the
land that has come forward to that
in our efforts to meet the five-year
housing land supply
thank you mr dobson councillor nan you
had a question
yes i'm grateful grateful to mr dudson
for
the report and i think the areas that
he's highlighted on page 11 are
absolutely right
and it's good that we're moving in a
positive direction under difficult
circumstances
i just wonder whether it's premature to
remove
r13 um i could be convinced that that is
the case
if mr dodson can tell us something about
any vacancy level at the moment you know
have we have we
filled all of the posts in the new
structure
and has turnover settled down to an
acceptable
level um through you chair thank you
thank you mr dobson sorry chairman i i
hadn't answered the second part
of the public question sorry
if i can take that first thank you
uh in respect of infrastructure
forecasting and delivery
the council is already reviewing its
evidence base for this and there is a
proposal going to strategy and resources
committee next week
to consult on a duty to cooperate
strategy
which will be the starting point for our
approach on matters
which is strategic and cross boundary
with various public bodies
such as education transport and health
those in real key infrastructure issues
that'll include essex county council
obviously as the highways authority and
the education authority
the odp originally was subject to an
independent examination by a planning
inspector
between 2014 and 2017
and he judged the plan to be legal and
sound
including the infrastructure aspects the
council
however does intend to approach the
challenge with a fresh perspective
update its evidence and understanding
and engage in a constructive dialogue
with necessary bodies
to improve upon infrastructure delivery
in the future and obviously through that
review there will again
be an examination in public and a full
consultation undertaken
thank you very much
sorry yes can you remember i can it
in relation to um the the closure of the
risk around the
um organizational change um
some of that was to do with um managing
organisational change and knowledge
um retention
we've put in much greater resilience in
terms of the the process mapping
that we've done and there's
there's less reliance now on individual
staff because there's
there's a collective mapping of all of
those processes and
so um should be a retention of corporate
knowledge
um on that basis in terms of
of filling the the roles i've not got
the
the latest staffing figures to hand
but we are at a a good level of staffing
now compared to certainly where we were
within transformation
um and just afterwards and in terms of
our sickness levels are as as low as
they've ever been
and our turnover rate of staff is low
we've also been able to fill some of
those key roles
um during the pandemic that we hadn't
been able to
to fill previously um some of the
the specialist planning roles um in
particular
and that really has built our capacity
so
subject to those giving you the exact
establishment figures at the moment you
know i'm
we're satisfied as a clt that that we've
been able to to manage those issues
through you chair thank you for that
answer mr dodson and um
if clt satisfied then so am i and i
think
that it's right then to remove r13 thank
you
councillor none councillor keys you had
your paddle up
there we go thank you chairman um mr did
we have much
uptake on the request for land do you
know
yes again i've not got the total figure
sample
but yeah we've had a large response
thank you councillor edward yes thank
you
um looking at um our seven
on the five-year land supply i think one
of the issues is the fact that
certainly in haybridge when planning
applications are approved
and i'm taking the countryside
application
it was approved in 2019
now the housing delivery
has not yet started when we're two years
into it
they have three years of course before
they have to dig a hole
so that might have been one of the
issues that
was not perhaps taken into account
because
so many houses have to be built per year
but they haven't started
so i think that is
one issue that could be um
that is causing this problem i'm not
sure about other developments but i know
about the habeas one
that is taken some time before
just to give an example there were three
developers in hebrews
in the garden suburb belaway persimmon
and countryside
both below and persimmon have built
their houses countryside haven't
so you're missing a lot of houses there
because they haven't actually built them
just wanted to make that point thank you
thank did you want to answer that yeah
i'm happy to to respond on that
yes absolutely that is that is part of
the
issue the the reserve matters and and
dealing with the
the issues after the the planning
application itself has been approved and
dealing with all of the conditions
has been one of the issues obviously the
pandemics had a
a part to play in that but um
i don't think it's it's the whole story
there there was some
sights that came forward that weren't
granted permission
as well in terms of some of the
decisions around
south molden that subsequently came back
to council or
through district planning and were
approved but obviously that caused a
delay
and that there's something of an irony
that we've passed the
housing delivery test for each of the
last three years
but because of the delay that's now
in place with some of that future
housing
then we've not got a five-year housing
land supply and it has been delays in
bringing forward some of those major
sites that's been the issue
council of fleming
thank you chair i have two questions the
first was about the
five-year land supply um whether we're
taking
uh mitigating measures uh it's widely
known in the building industry that
there's a severe shortage
of both labor and materials at the
moment you can't get timber
prices have risen 50 percent on
everything you can't get roof tiles
cement
so i just wanted to be reassured that we
are factoring in that
situation into calculations is my first
question
and then with your permission chair i
have another question
i'm happy to answer that one first
chairman
we would love to factor in those issues
um and representations were made to
government through
the issues of the pandemic the the
supply chain
slow in and that that was going to
clearly have an impact on the five-year
housing land supply
but at the moment they are saying the
rules as they
they stood held so we can't change any
of the figures
based on those those delays that will
happen they're just
something we have to take into account
in the figures that we've got not got a
five-year housing land supply
thank you chair uh so my concern is
is that the situation is actually going
to deteriorate
even further than we have at the moment
and my second question
was about
page 15
the covert 19 economic recovery
and transformation plan if mr dobson
could elaborate further
page r10
to develop pure failure to develop jobs
to support the growing
population yeah yeah it's because i'm
not on um yeah mod gov i'm on the
pdf version it doesn't have a paid page
15.
yes there's a um economic um
economic recovery and transformation
plan that has has been um
created much of the detail of that has
been taken through the
reset and recovery working group
highlighting some of the
work around the economic um
initiatives that have been put in place
um around
keep it local click it local supporting
local businesses the extra support
that's going
to go into the um
the um tourism sector um and
as a as a corporate leadership team with
we're looking at the the recovery along
with the
reset and recovery group around economic
recovery but also around
alternative ways of of working and
future ways of working
and also the community recovery
and as i think it was mentioned at reset
and recovery group there's
there's initiatives like looking to to
bring in additional staff around
economic development using the welcome
back funding
and those initiatives
thank you joe if i could come back um
thank you mr dodson i was just a little
bit surprised to see that
because um i've never seen that plan and
i'm the chair and i know that counsellor
still
sits on it as does councillor channel so
it would be helpful for members of the
working group if you would
share that with us certainly i thought
it had been through as a whole but
certainly that all of the presentations
that come
through from that operational document
are the detail that has been shared with
the committee they all stem from
from that piece of work that outlined
that approach thank you
thank you i'm going to go to councillor
stevens
and then councillor chana
councillor stevens thank you chair
i've got four questions if i may but
they're not criticisms this is me being
new and
on a learning curve um i'm i was quite
surprised not to see the environment
anything about the environment in here
the climate crisis has got to be a huge
risk
i appreciate this is about corporate
risk
but i'd like to know why that isn't in
there do you want to answer that before
i ask the others
yes happy too um it's not on the
corporate
risk register but as a council we have
because it is a corporate risk
register we have recognized the
the um as a council the environmental
issues and
declared um a climate emergency at full
council
with a view to addressing the council's
what the council can do and what the
council can pledge around that to
improve matters
through the um um climate
and environment action plan which is
being put together
and will come back to council in um
final quarter
final calendar quarter of of this year
we have had some corporate risks
on there before um relating to flooding
and the effects
of climate change um but that was around
the the coordination
of of that but it's it's something we
can look at again obviously but it it is
because it's that corporate
risk registering risks to the
through your chair organization i ask
that between
questions that we only have one mic on a
path in the tres mic
each time no sorry i mean cancer
students when you ask your question you
get your mic on and then
the director answered and
sorry about that r29 which was a risk
of failure to deliver because of covid
does the information in here also
reflect
people who are one step removed from the
council itself so service providers
um like housing associations for example
please
yes when we look at the the delivery of
council services
obviously some of those are delivered
through third parties
and partnerships so it considers all of
all of those yeah
thank you r14 mentions the difficulty of
recruiting
good people into the planning team i
didn't see anything in there about
if that's not possible therefore trying
to recruit people who have good aptitude
or
developing existing staff who have good
aptitude by sending them on
appropriate training
yes we've not got that in there as a
specific mitigation
but um we have over a number of years
developed people
through apprenticeship schemes and
people have gone through
um planning training while they've been
um part of the council but there's
this often there are gaps that come
that they need to have somebody of a
level of seniority
to fill those posts and those the ones
that have been most challenging
um to fill in the past although at the
moment
we're doing relatively well certainly
better at the moment than we've done in
a long time in terms of filling those
posts
and your last question okay thank you
yes the last one on
r30 which was about um the management of
the
election i appreciate this is for the
previous quarter but now that that's
behind us would we not look at closing
that one
yes and in effect it was reduced
i think i had it down as one that one
that was being reduced and that was
reduced
as we approached the election obviously
we had the
the um risk assessments the organization
was
was in place and the risk was
diminishing
and it was delivered um absolutely fine
um
so yeah we we reduced that but this is
the risk risk report for the end of
quarter
four um but yes that's now being removed
because the election's over thank you
councillor channel you had your paddle
up
thank you madam chairman for allowing me
to speak um i've got a few questions if
i may
um can i just say um i was going to
start off
um the same aspect that council and
undid actually
regarding r13 failure to manage the
impact of organizational change
and i'm not being critical either but
obviously we are here to challenge and
this is just a point of challenge
bearing in mind what i've read
throughout the documents in in this
committee schedule tonight
it seems there's various areas to me
where actually there are
resources that are perhaps strained and
indeed
there's an issue about planning later on
in the papers talking about
the review and it's still challenging
regarding planning and recruitment and
also i think
the fact is we've got covid now the new
organizational really came into effect
with the committee change going back to
i think october 19
before we knew it we'd moved into
kovid's shutdown virtually in march 20.
so have we really had enough time to
judge all this bearing in mind the covet
equation
and i think mr um dodson partly answered
that but i am concerned
especially when you read within in the
appendix about r13 and what it states
there
regarding that and it says potential for
change i
have to say i consider it perhaps too
premature
just at this time to alter that
r13 and remove it wholly from this
committee's remit
um do you want me to stop there madam
chairman do you want to answer that or
something
yes thank you um
as i said i think there has been
significant
change to um
that that's now been embedded um
we've updated the corporate plan to
reflect that we've undertaken
resource reviews um and additional post
post funding obviously at the end of
quarter four some of that those
appointments hadn't been made
and we've increased capacity since then
certainly
around planning there's been additional
appointments
following on from that um you know as i
said
previously i still think subject to the
the points raised that
we're comfortable to to recommend that
um
to be to be closed
boy i forgot to turn on michael
um get up
yes you might you may carry on if it's
still on the couch i can't get
registered now
i'll try this one
no i'm red that's that's fine come on
yeah i'm gonna open now don't have my
green light
all right i'm open okay right if i may
then madam chairman um
if i could go to page 15 and r15 it says
about
um proposals regarding the budget
process highlighting
the minimum level we're going to fall
behind bearing in mind which is pretty
close 2324
and it says that proposals to address
the budget gap are being developed and
will come forward as part of the budget
setting process
at what point of those budget
gap proposals to address the budget gap
will members be involved
and will it can will it contain about a
suite of member seminars
as last time i think we had the finance
working group and we were told that the
that working group was confidential
and i just asked the question to my view
what should be confidential in that
working group that other members
shouldn't be aware of
and also bearing in mind the amount of
business grants
that we've been distributing for the
government and bearing in mind there
could be another suite of funding
in relation to that in june and
depending on how we process those
we may receive extra funding or not
could we be given an
update perhaps on that requirement
thank you i will pass that to mr leslie
yeah thank you chair so the finance
working group obviously set up to deal
with those
pacific engagement um side of it from
the budget there's a finance working
group meeting
taking place next week agenda for that
has been circulated and i believe that
is
on mod.gov now as well which i believe
all members have access to
so i don't believe there's anything
confidential within
that set so that's the forum we're using
and indeed that pack does contain
some of the uh financials
the sustainability proposals that are
being developed
in consultation of course uh with member
engagement as part of that
working group so that's on there in
terms of
the business grants we're looking to pay
the final lot
of the additional restrictions grants
over the coming
a couple of weeks which will then give
us another tranche as you quite
rightly say post the end of the month
which i believe
is around about 565
000 pounds of additional funding that we
could
achieve and then we'll be looking to
distribute that again as quickly as
possible
after the after we receive it
in terms of the new burdens funding
that's the funding that we get
to distribute those we have had money in
again
i believe that was 166 000 pounds
that we received for the grants we've
we've paid a date
hopefully as we're paying out more
grants we may get another
new burdens grant for for this year but
i've not had any further
confirmation or indication around that
thank you mr leslie councillor chandler
do you have any more questions
yes i do just on these ones if i may
made you want me to give them all in one
go because they're pretty short
questions would that be helpful
gone yeah if they're all for the same
officer that would be lovely
oh well um i don't know quite who
decides who's gonna answer so
r10 in fact councillor fleming's raised
the very point i was going to ask about
that
plan because i wasn't clear where how
members were going to be seeing that
can i just ask i know the risk has been
increased but is 16
high enough bearing in mind the
importance of economic growth or if you
like
your or actually helping it revive
for once of a better word bearing in
mind it really has an effect on lots of
things
health well-being mental health jobs
a host of other aspects do rely on
people's
economic welfare if you like so that's
one question on that
on r25 can someone say what the figure
was of the unachieved
savings and r29 refers to a member
working group
which one are we referring to um
is it the covid 19 reset and recovery i
wasn't quite
clear and regarding our three regarding
bellway developments and we were talking
about we are lacking in diligence
um regarding certain areas can that just
be explained what diligence were we
lacking in
and again r14 is nine too low for that
r14 bearing in mind the issues regarding
planning
although i appreciate what mr dodson has
just said thank you madam chairman
thank you mr dobson
sorry there were too many questions at
once for me there
um
r10 should take can you just
go back to our 10 what was the
um i said council of families raised the
very points i was going to because i
can't recollect the plan being delivered
through members at that working group if
i'm honest
um maybe elements of it but the
important point i wonder well bearing in
mind we've said we've increased the risk
and how important economic growth is
or if you like actually revival of it
following covid
is that well that's been increased is
that overall risk rating high enough
bearing in mind the effects economic
prosperity recovery review whatever you
want to call it
has on health and well-being mental
health jobs
it has an effect on the whole gamut of
things you know the quality of life of
the district in fact
is that do we feel that risk rating is
sufficient of 16
yes thank you the the um as i said
earlier
that there was an operational economic
recovery plan which has
been produced the information that has
gone to the
the board i'm happy to absolutely happy
to to share that that plan
and that's not an issue at all
in terms of the um the overall figure
um obviously the the impact figure has
always been for
and the impact figure doesn't change
that was
what it was always estimated at the
um the likelihood has increased um
to a four i think you know as i said
there's uncertainty
around covid um there are challenges
in the economy at the moment
but there's also forecasts of seven and
a half percent growth
in the next year in the in the economy
nationally
so i think to to go to a five on that
and underscore
20 would at this point be um
slightly excessive given given that
there there is
cause for um
posit that there are positives as well
as negatives but obviously we keep it
under review
and a score of 16 is a significant risk
on the corporate risk register in any
case
councillor janna i'm aware of sort of
some of the time can some of your
questions be answered
um via emails from the
um officers when they've got
some of the information you need
if that's your wish random chairman i'll
do it that way but um
i mean i'm quite happy for you if you
want to quickly run through the other
ones
um to the others but i'm just
conscious of time that was all so you
had you had a couple more
so we will take those as you'd started
but
if if the answers are going to be long
maybe the officers can
send you an email on the answers so
if you'd like to ask your next question
oh well yeah that's okay
just the yes okay um r25 what figure
was the unauthorized savings unachieved
savings
i'll achieve i think
yeah i believe that was in the february
council report 133
000 uh transformation savings and
achieved and it remained at that
yeah yeah that's what we um yeah that's
what we
didn't take forward and r29 what was the
member working group referred to is it
the kovid 19 reset and recovery working
group
yes it is worded with a number of facets
made me wonder if it was that one
yes it is okay and regarding um
r3 where bellway development is referred
to and it mentions about um we need
our lacking in diligence what areas is
that diligence we see we need to improve
regarding this to learn from that
experience
i don't even know the beltway
development to be honest
i believe that that was where there were
changes to the
um required size of um
developments and there had been changes
um and i'm
i'm summarizing this from from memory i
understand there have been changes to
the regulations around the size of
properties
um and the requirements on them um
and
under the conditions that went out
originally they were approved and
as the regulations had changed there
wasn't then the opportunity
to to change it um it's quite it's quite
involved i'm happy to
to answer that in more detail outside of
the meeting but i believe that that's
what that relates to
yes thank you madam chairman i would
appreciate that and i'll leave it there
i won't ask the last one
it's another one i think it's a bit too
low in the ratings but i'm sure mr
dodson will explain
in a similar vein to which he did
regarding my concerns about the other
r rating thank you thank you if you
would like to email that question to mr
dobson then he can
answer that after this meeting
councillor fleming sorry thank you chair
uh unconscious of time so just quickly i
wanted to
um ask mr dodson about r13
failure to manage impact of
organizational change particularly in
relation to the current
administrative backlog in the planning
department
which has been raised with me by
individuals across the district and also
parish councils
i'm told that comments are
submitted via the planning portal and
also delivered to offices
and sent in by email are not being
uploaded onto the system
for public view if you would like to
comment on that thank you that's
i'm afraid that's not an issue that i've
been made aware of so
i'm not able to to comment on that i
don't know if um
mr holmes is is aware of that
thank you chairman not specifically no i
know there have been issues in the past
sort of planning pool too it's it's an
external um site which we uh don't
directly manage ourselves but i'm more
than happy to look at the
instances that you've you've mentioned
um and see if i can get into the into
the resolution for that for you
thank you chair if i can just come back
i have raised it with mr lee
and he acknowledges that there is a
three-week backlog
with the admin of of comments onto the
system
thank you thank you councillor channel
if i can ask that you email
thanks to mr holmes or mr dobson and
then
you can they can look into it for you
and come back to you
thank you is there any other member
questions
now so i moved the recommendations
earlier so the recommendation one was to
review the corporate
uh risk register in appendix one and
provide
comment and feedback for consideration
little two was the members are assured
for this report that the corporate
review is being
managed effectively and little three
that the members challenge where the
committee feels that the council
corporate goals may not be achieved is
everybody happy to accept that by
succinct agree thank you
we move on then to item six on the
agenda
which is the review of corporate
performance quarter four
this is found on pages 14 at 19 to 40
and a call on mr dobson to present the
report
mr dobson thank you chairman
this is the end of year performance
report and the last that reports against
the outcomes prior to the
the corporate plan refresh
clearly it's been a year like no other
when we've had to continue to deliver
against a background of a pandemic
including two periods of national
lockdown
despite that background i think this is
a positive report and shows good
progress in general over the last 12
months
section 3.3 of the covering report gives
a broad outcome
update for each of the thematic
strategies in the corporate plan
section 3.4 of the covering report then
highlights the specific indicators
highlighted at risk
which means that delivery has not
achieved what was set out
these have been highlighted in earlier
performance reporting and wider member
communications and a lot of these have
been impacted by the pandemic
conversely there are some areas where
we've still achieved an outcome
um but it was not how we identified it
would first be achieved for example
community engagement
and support for shielding groups would
have contributed to reducing social
isolation but was obviously never part
of the
the delivery design and um channel shift
was outlined to supporting those who
came into the offices to go online
and support them with that obviously the
offices have been closed but the shift
to online
has happened as more people have
naturally
embraced technology during the the covid
outbreak
sitting behind the covering report
appendix 1 gives the detailed list of
indicators
and updates that inform the the high
level assessment
work is finalizing now on the the
corporate plan
refresh outcome measurements as recently
highlighted in the member seminar
and member feedback from that session
will inform the design and build
of the the framework for the coming year
thank you chairman thank you mr dobson
before i go to the
questions can i move the recommendations
that the members
review the information set out in the
this report and appendix one with
priority focus given to the strategic
outcome level performance and little two
that the members confirm they are
assured through this review that
corporate
performance is being managed effectively
can have
secondary i haven't taken those
recommendations
thank you mr councillor jarvis
councillor none
uh yes thank you chad i'm grateful to mr
dodson for the report
and i agree with him it's been a year
plus
like no other and i think on that basis
it's amazing really that there are more
red dots
than we've got but if i can turn to page
34 please
the maintaining open spaces it
specifically talks about a management
plan
for the prom as it relates to green flag
status
and you know i think what's important
really as we go
forward is that that management plan is
a wider plan
that takes into account all of the
strategic issues
relating to the prom that's my first
observation and my second observation
relates to
the other red dot on 34 which is
air quality and
things seem to have gone very quiet in
terms of market hill
uh and the air quality work and i know
that
the last meeting that i went to there
was a delay from essex county council in
terms of monitoring work
and we were promised further monitoring
and it and it didn't
manifest itself and i just wondered
where we were with that now
thank you mr dobson
mr hans thank you chairman yes on those
two points uh first the management plans
um i absolutely agree that those
management plans are essential and as
wide-ranging as possible
and they have been scheduled for some
time but unfortunately
other workload has has created a sort of
backlog
but i have discussed it with the team
and it will be one of the the team's
objectives uh this year to deliver that
management plan i'd like to see that
come to
to council in the autumn or into the
winter certainly
and so that we can plan appropriately
for next year so have an assurance that
plan will cover the whole of the park
all aspects of its management
maintenance and care um and that will be
coming to members later this year
um on the second point regarding uh air
quality
you're absolutely right the county
council have delayed the surveys it's
because
traffic levels aren't yet or weren't
certainly and we're talking about q4
here
um at anywhere near normal levels so
therefore they were waiting for a form
of recovery so that the
exercise could be constructive i checked
with the officer this afternoon about
progress
um he will be calling another meeting of
the working group
um we weren't successful in our funding
bid to accelerate the action plan
so some options will be put forward to
members which may involve the district
council funding or alternative
looking for an alternative funding
source um so
again an assurance that that is coming
back to members for consideration
thank you mr very grateful to us thank
you
thank you councillor none any other
members of this committee got a question
councillor keys cheers madam chairman
um it's a question that i'm asked a lot
of the time
improve access to superfast broadband
across the district
on track and progressing how does that
is that assessed because it's certainly
um
a question i get asked quite a lot when
we put men on the moon 60 years ago and
we can't get phone signals
in great tottenham i just wondered how
the percentages has worked where it says
on track
what how is that assessed
those thank you through your chat that
it's from the um
superfast essex steering group um
figures that that they produce um
which i believe we're
they've delivered ahead of schedule in
terms of the the target that they had
um for the district and are
forecasting i believe 97 coverage
by the end of next year um i'd have to
check the exact figures but but
certainly the figures from the last
meeting that the officers attended
they're they're ahead of schedule where
they they expected to be at this point
okay thank you mr dobson thank you mr
case do i put
any other members of the committee that
like to ask a question
i'll go to councillor channel um thank
you madam chairman
but council announced actually honed in
on what i was going to be asking so i
won't
duplicate that question about the
working group and
the areas all i've got to say in his
manager and perhaps it's me the way i
was reading it regarding the air quality
and i'm sure there is a reasoning for
this which i've somehow
not quite picked up with my brain cells
but on page 30 improved air quality we
show on track
slow progress of our qma and it's shown
as green
then when we go to page 34 we have
two um under d one is improved air
quality
and the other one's improved air quality
once the development of aqma action plan
yes i know that's been agreed but it
mentions the need for the traffic flow
assessment again is shown as green
and then we have improved air quality
where mdc recently failed in
the funding as though that's the pivotal
thing and it's the funding that affects
it and that's red
i just wondered would it not make sense
to group those together because i found
that quite confusing and bearing in mind
in the overarching report
it does show that air quality is one of
the areas at risk so
i found some of the green and the red a
bit
incongruent not the red because like
that tied in with what i considered was
written in the main embodiment of the
report and in german
thank you mr dobson yes
i totally agree that there were too many
outputs
previously in outcomes and that that was
as the um the member seminar
said well as as the the corporate plan
um that was approved by by counselling
in february
agreed it reduced the number of outcomes
from 30 odd
down to um 17 um
so it makes it much more manageable
and in that review and the the
finalization of the forward
performance monitoring for next year
we're looking to simplify that
i think there was at the start of last
year it's possibly legitimate that
the action plan was one issue to to get
that approved because there was a
statutory route for that
and then delivering on that was was a
second
um outcome but i think certainly at this
point once we've got approval of that
first
action plan that that it should be a
single outcome yes
sorry it's a long answer to assure sure
thank you
so it wasn't me sort of getting too
confused then there was
a point to be made by seeing what i've
seen on that
appendix thank you thank you are there
any other questions
counselor let me thank you chair
i just wanted to through you asked mr
dodson about page 36
prosperity outcomes uh partnership
working to provide an enterprise
center it's down at under review
i was hoping that we could have a little
bit more detail
on why it's under review and where that
sort of originated from to put it under
review
thank you um
yes the the there were a number of
studies done that the enterprise center
was originally part of the central area
master plan there was a further study
undertaken
uh i think in 2019
that looked at um
a preferred site for that and put a bid
in
through south east lep for funding um
to build that enterprise centre that was
unsuccessful
at the time and we looked
to what was still continuing to look for
funding looked at
alternatives and there were other other
projects that came forward that
potentially an enterprise center could
have been brought forward in a different
way
i think at the moment it's under review
um because
one camp will be reviewed as part of the
the ldp review
but but also obviously with the the
current
economic market it's
it may be a high risk for the council to
go into something that would be
a partially commercial um approach to
economic development in delivering an
enterprise centre
so i think we need to review the
the evidence and the the basis on which
we were we were looking to take that
forward to see if it's still the right
thing
to do and we'll have the the best way to
bring forward a boost to
molden's economy
okay if there are no other questions
we have moved the recommendations and
they have been seconded
so therefore will members um
like to agree these on ascent
thank you we move on to
item 7 the health and safety update
found on pages 41-46 and i called on mr
holmes to present the report
thank you chairman members there were
two incidents uh during this quarter and
this uh it refers to the final quarter
of the year
quarter four uh between january and
march 2021.
um they say there were two uh issues one
one accident and one near miss
the near miss was regarding uh the
gravedigging staff
in one of our cemeteries where a piece
of equipment fell into the grave
uh into onto the employee um and the
other was an accident uh sorry nearly
missing the employer i should say as it
was near miss
and the other was an actual accident
when a council vehicle reversed into an
employee's car which was parked in the
car park itself
there were no incidents of unacceptable
behavior during this period
um you'll see that there has been little
progress with regard to the health and
safety action plan
i'll come back to that shortly however
amendments are being made to other
arrangements such as the first aid
procedures of the council
we've got a new structure making sure
that the first aid is uh approach
appropriate
to the new structure itself and risk
assessments are being undertaken and
reviewed on a as
needed basis and i think a good example
of that would be the the local elections
where the team undertook all the risk
assessments for the polling stations
and the count centre itself so work is
underway uh as an
as unrequired um obviously the the
action plan you'll find that
appendix one and two sets out some some
uh other overarching uh work that needs
to be done
and i've sought an assurance that we can
actually move forward on this now
because it has actually
uh been sort of um held in that position
for some time and i'm advised that
that that work will actually commence in
q3 of this year so after this summer
there's a number of pieces of work that
the team need to do
around licensing but once that is done
they will actually pick that up and
refresh that action plan so i'd be very
hopeful that
as we get to the end of q3 q4 we will be
able to give you a
fuller update on the action plan thank
you chairman thank you mr hans
i moved the recommendations little one
that members review the information
are set out in the report and associated
appendis
and little two that members confirm that
they are assured that through this
update health and safety is being
managed
effectively can i have a happy to say
much
thank you councillor jarvis do i have
any questions
counsellor nun well it's more of a
statement really
on page 43
there's a throwaway line about risk
assessments
and reference to covid19
i i think that um that there's more to
it than that
you know i think this council should be
commended when i say this council
officers
for the work that they've done in
relation to
risk assessments around covert 19 and
the way that they're trying to do all
they can to keep members
and officers and the public safe
not just here in the council chamber but
also at the football
stadium so you know i think that
that that should be that should be
mentioned in this report that they're
very effective
risk assessments um so that's it's not
question it's a statement really thank
you thank you councillor nan
councillor channel i need to have sorry
did i have any other members of the
committee that wanted a question
as councillor edwards
um just going through this i have a
question regarding fire marshals
do we have farm marshals here esther
holmes
sorry gentlemen could you so you could
repeat that question fire marshals yes
how can i help with that pun how can i
help with that question do we have fire
marshals
yes there are fire marshals in the
building where it's normally occupied
and we've got caretaking staff here this
evening who obviously fire safety
trained
um but staff are trained in evacuation
and fire procedures so yes we do have
and we have regular fire drills yeah the
the staff do practice we haven't done
for some time because we've simply not
been here but
uh yeah there's a testing regime
assembly points around the building and
uh yes we do test i didn't see anyone
here that's all thank you very much
any other members of the committee not
councillor chana
well thank you adam chairman i'm sure mr
holmes will be able to answer this one
he's explained about the accident near
misses can i just
so i understand this what about
accidents which have involved council
vehicles and may have hit
residents cars and i'm sure mr holmes
knows what i'm talking about
because i was got involved myself in one
where the resident actually came to me
so that is is that included in these
statistics or is that aligned and
recorded elsewhere because i'm not quite
sure
and then i've got one about the hand
vibration policy and training
after that madam chairman if i may
chairman i think normal motor accidents
if i put it that way i wouldn't
necessarily be captured by this report
there's more to do with the staff
some members are aware obviously we do
have a motor fleet um from time to time
we do have accidents
um they are dealt with by the council's
insurers um and that is reported the
normal way so that is a separate process
this is uh reported because it was a
council vehicle reversing into a members
of staff's car
and councillor general i'll let you have
your second question
that's interesting what about when staff
as taft cars hit members cars has
happened to me but we'll probably
go there whether the same reporting
occurs because i don't think it did
regarding the hand vibration policy and
the training i wasn't quite sure has the
hand vibration policy now be concluded
because it was waiting for stakeholder
involvement then it said training was
done as a result of a risk assessment
and then it appears in the action plan
for this year as well
and at what point then i'm not quite
clear at which point your health and
safety policies then go forward to
council um because to my knowledge i
think they have to be approved by
council
sharon i'm not sure i'd have to come
back to you in writing on the actual
policy when it was coming
has been to council or is coming to
council but what i can assure you is
that the staff have
had the necessary training the risk
assessments have been carried out
um over the last few months regarding
that um so
if if members are happy i will get that
detail and then put it in right into the
committee
thank you mr holmes thank you councillor
chana councillor edward would you hug
you
yes thank you sorry can i come back on
something else um
health and safety training for our
community engagement team when they're
out and about
um for instance anti-social behavior
and such like um and safeguarding issues
so i presume that i know there are
trained in safeguarding issues
but what about health and safety in
terms of
anti-social behaviour example for their
safety
yes i mean this area of work would come
under another risk assessment
effectively
um perhaps an example of that was we've
now moved to having body-worn cameras
now that was again at the request of the
team because that was down to
not it was a de-escalation situation
often when when
actually something is being recorded it
can de-escalate a situation
also it's evidential so through normal
working practices through risk
assessments whether it be loan working
whether it be in contact with staff on
rota or
using equipment such as cctv then those
are those are carried out
and absolutely if there's any specific
training that's identified by the staff
then
that that's how they receive it
thank you if there's no other questions
i will move
the recommendations so they have been
put forward and they have been seconded
so is the committee to happy to
accept those
thank you item eight on the agenda draft
annual governance statement 2021
on pages 47-62 and a call on mr dobson
to give the republic
thank you chairman the annual governance
statement is a statutory document
which explains the the processes and
procedures in place to enable the
council to carry out its functions
effectively
since 2011 it doesn't need to be
included in the statements of
accounts and last year malden published
it as a document in its own right
to highlight the importance of
governance governance
assurance you'll see in the document
that we've highlighted some of the
governance achievements that took place
in
2021 and this includes frameworks and
training that were put in place in
response to
the covert emergency measures and new
ways of working
looking forwards we've also identified
an action plan
for the coming year although there are
no areas of
significant governance concerns
highlighted by us or
the internal auditors the action table
builds on best practice and progress
and will be reported back to this
committee
and the committee is asked to approve
the annual governance statement and
agree the tracking of the actions
identified to be reported back in due
course
thank you chairman
the recommendations for this um
report are recommendations one the
performance governance
and audit committee approved the annual
government statement at appendix a
little too that the performance
governance and audit committee
monitor the progress of the action plan
and little three that the quarterly
report
of annual governance action plan is
provided for
performance governance and audit
committee review
[Music]
can i have a second for that general
second
are those recommendations thank you
councillor jarvis
do i have any members questions
council of fleming
no actually have you changed your mind
now
if i have no members questions can
are you all happy to accept these
recommendations
thank you good report i move on to
agenda item nine the annual governance
statement
actions update we move to agenda item
nine found on pages
63 to 66 and i call on mr dobson again
to give
the republic thank you chairman um this
report gives members an update on the
actions highlighted in the 2019-20
annual government's
governance statement um actions
identified were around improving best
practice
rather than any particular particular
governance concerns
most of the actions are complete there
are a few that are still in progress and
these have been identified and built
into the action table
um for continuation um in the the latest
annual governance statement
to can you to continue to track delivery
of best practice
thank you chairman thank you i'll move
to the recommendation
the recommendation is to review the ags
action table and updates below and
challenge where necessary do i have a
second
i'm having a second recommendation thank
you councillor jarvis do i have any
committee
members questions
councillor fleming thank you chair it's
my questions related to partly the
agenda item before and then just
in context it's a general question um
in relation to the emergency powers
did we have to repeal them are actually
they still
in effect ongoing
and we voted to instate them i just i'm
quite interested
to know whether they had to be repealed
at all
um we had to vote to remove them
through you chairman i don't think
council voted to
um put in emergency powers
they put in a covid19 interim measures
group which was to make decisions in
lieu of committees
um and for the that that group to advise
the or for the um
directors to consult that group in
making decisions
um under the normal emergency powers so
there are emergency powers that are
written into the constitution
and those were used but in lieu what
what happened was the meetings were
suspended
and it was the kovid 19 interim measures
group i think that was
was new um that lapsed
um at the time that it ended and
obviously
committees started again so
we operate with our normal committee
system
but there are always emergency powers in
place
that can be used to deal with
emergencies
whether that happens because of short
time scales and something that there's
not an opportunity to take it through
a longer process or if there's anything
that happens so those emergency
and powers always sit there
is there any other member member
questions councillor stevens
thank you on page 63 it refers to a peer
review of
scrutiny arrangements but then goes on
to say
it wasn't actually a peer review but we
considered that it was okay
i paraphrased can you explain that
please thank you
yeah so there was an update of the um
the overview and scrutiny
um process um and i think
there was there was a discussion around
a peer review but the um
the lga was used to to come in
and do some both some review of those
processes
and some training around that um
so i think that has as highlighted in
the report
that it was felt there wasn't necessary
to undertake a full peer review having
done that piece of work
thank you very much thank you do i have
any other committee members
questions no i will go to councillor
channel then
well thank you madam chairman it's to do
on page 63 and i'm sure mr leslie
i have the answer to this one about the
public involvement and budget
consultation as part of our annual
strategic cycle
last budget round we didn't i believe
have any um input from the public which
i think in other years may have been the
case um is will this be through our
citizens panel i don't know i actually
haven't heard that utilized
in well for months and years maybe so is
that no longer in
in existence um and i wonder if you
could just give an indication bearing in
mind
the draft budget consultation has been
prepared and is currently being
finalized
what it constitutes and at what stage
would it be built into the budget
setting timetable if he could give an
indication
of um whereabouts in that timetable it
falls thank you
yeah so we've prepared um
a survey and it consists of utilizing
the
online facilities that we have here so
it'll be an online
survey that we gave to go out and be
publicized for the residents
they'll be able to complete that survey
and then we'll be able to feed that uh
back
to members uh and just parts of the
working group
in terms of the budget cycle so that's
the process at the moment uh we're
hoping to go out shortly with the budget
survey but that's
still to be determined and then we'll be
able to report back an update a bit
further
thank you council stevens
thank you i know that an online survey
is probably more accurate and the best
way of doing it
in many ways but will we also remember
that not everyone has access to
online facilities please thank you
thank you yes we can look at that
but if there is no more questions i will
move to go to the recommendations they
have been
put to you they have been seconded can i
take that you are agreeing these by a
cent
thank you
so item 10 on the agenda is the annual
report on whistleblowing we move to
pages
67 to 68 and i call on mr leslie to give
the report
thank you chairman so by convention this
report is provided annually to the
committee
uh it identifies the number of
whistleblowing incidents that had
occurred
in the year which was none the
whistleblowing policy provides an
internal process for those with serious
concerns about any
council's work or activity to blow the
whistle or raise it
key objectives of the policy include
encouraging legitimate concerns to be
raised protects whistleblowers from
reprisal
provides a procedure for whistleblowing
ensure
whistleblowing concerns get a response
and gives advice on what to do if they
believe the
response is not good enough
thank you i moved to the recommendation
so the recommendation is little one to
consider the report
do i have a seconder for that
recommendation
abilities taking that recommendation
gentlemen thank you councillor jarvis do
i have any questions from any members
councillor fleming thank you chair
um i just wanted to ask mr leslie
whether we conduct exit
interviews because often employees like
to comment on the way out
don't they and actually they can be
those
it can be a very beneficial process and
whether we record that information
and whether this committee would be able
to access that information
thank you mr leslie
yes we do conduct uh exit interviews and
if anything of concern is within them
that gets raised
i don't believe there's anything
currently that goes to committee
around that but perhaps i could look at
the
the reporting process and consider where
it goes and perhaps come back
on that that's okay councillor jarvis
you had your hand up
thank you karen um my question uh
relates
to uh how familiar uh staff might be i'm
conscious of
paragraph 3.4 which says there's been no
no whistleblowing concerns
and my concern might be if if if that
had been the case my perhaps that's my
first question if that is the case
for several years uh uh can we be given
greater confidence that
the whistleblowing system procedure is
known to staff
can officers confirm for example that
there is annual training
so that and can they confirm that there
is some system
for recording uh sort of near misses
because uh
a report that tells me that there have
been no instances
and if officers confirm to me which they
might do
but there'll be no instances for a
number of years sort of whilst that look
good
looks good at first glance could suggest
that perhaps there's a fundamental
weakness
in the system fundamentally it's not
being used
thank you councillor jobs mr esley so in
terms of
the policy being available it's on
fresh service for uh to be accessed
it's also within the fraud policy
website as well so if
people don't know necessarily the
neighbour policy um usually as a search
for food we'll be able to come up
identify that section and it's in the
fraud section
within fresh surf that's available there
we conducted uh
full training uh with officers
just under under a year ago uh now and
that
involved some of the key officers in
resources housing
revenues and benefits areas
around those key key risk services and
part of that included
the whistleblowing and what we're also
doing as well
is to put that on the all staff email
that gets circulated just to make sure
that
that promotes it further with all staff
so hopefully that
gets the message out there and it can be
raised if anything
of concern comes counselor challenge
yeah
thank you for that for that answer if i
might just add i think it uh it would be
a good idea
not just to have it on on the system but
to ensure that
uh full training is given to all staff
not just senior officers
so that everybody is familiar with the
whistleblowing procedure and that they
know how
and and how they should go about making
such a return and what the implications
are
um so that it can be used to full effect
because you know indeed if there are
issues we'd like
people to mention and refer through we
can only then
make improvements which we can benefit
from if there is if nobody feels they're
using the whistleblowing system if
people don't know it can be a great
shame because it can give the illusion
of having
a good system in place but you know if
people are too frightened to use it
because they don't know about it
and then obviously that's a missed
opportunity thank you chair
thank you mr leslie
yeah thank you so yes the training um
not just for senior officers but for the
key risk areas but i think the point
around all
um staff members still remains and in
fact
we're looking at actually our full
training and whether we can perhaps do
something for all staff
around that which would then include the
whistleblowing policy
as part of that so it's definitely
something that's under consideration
currently
does any other members of the committee
have a question
no i will go to councillor channel then
thank you madam tim council of jarvis
actually touched very much on what i was
going to ask
and therefore can i add my adjunct to
that which i was going to be asking or
thought might be a reason behind it
bearing in mind covid and we're talking
about this municipal ear if we have been
out really of the offices serve officers
for really that municipal year does he
feel that's had an influence on it and
that could result in why there's been no
reports because working from home
you're not actually in the work
environment where more things might
become
sort of pertinent or you become aware of
you know
telephone calls or whatever or other
things you might see because you're
working in a bit of isolation so for
teams meetings and
emails so that was one point and then i
noticed it is an internal document but
it does say obviously that it is for
employers to disclose any concerns about
malpractice by any colleague or
counsellor
now counselor to counsellor we're very
well aware what we can do we have a code
of conduct and we can make
complaints etc what about if a
counsellor
may have i want to whistle blow
regarding concerns they have in respect
of officers
does the whistleblowing policy account
for that as well
and if not what route do members have in
terms of whistleblowing
um regarding officers thank you
mr leslie okay
so in terms of historical figures uh a
look back
uh i think three possibly four years
i've not seen that there has been any
reports of whistleblowing either so
again with covert we haven't had any
more so
i couldn't really say whether codes had
any impact because we're still this or
the same at zero in the past
around that in terms of members yes they
can use the policy
in place to raise any of those concerns
so it's equally valid
for councillors as well thank you thank
you
if there's no other questions i will
go to the recommendations i put the
recommendations before you they have
been seconded
do members want to accept those on
sushi lovely thank you
item 11 is
the s one a section 106 update these are
found on pages 69 to 72 and i call on mr
dobson to
present the report thank you chairman
uh the purpose of this report is to
update members on the section 106
monitoring processes
and to gain members endorsement for the
continuing and effective management of
the council's section 106
responsibilities
as the report indicates the last half
year has been one of peaks and troughs
in terms of section 106 income
flows uh the winter season and
disruptions from the covid working
arrangements in the building industry
coupled with the desire to take
to pace section 106 payments in a manner
which stays in step with receipts from
house sales has meant that receipts have
been more disjointed
um than in other years um the section
106 officer will be doing visits during
june and july and actually
it will be more of the the planning team
um
to redress our understanding of what's
happened on the ground and really
get a good picture of of where we are
and consider whether further
payments have been triggered but not
paid
while the income stream may have been
disrupted the section 106 officer has
been maintaining pressure on both the
nhs and other
council departments and partners to make
sure that the expenditure deadlines are
not being missed
a letter was recently sent to the nhs
clinical commissioning
group to offer more support and they've
recognised the
sense of urgency to get the anticipated
improvements to their services around
the district completed as more homes get
built
they're aware of our keenly felt desire
to to avoid developer funding being
returned through a lack of expenditure
in
in legal deadlines and have in fact um
since the report was written um
increased their capacity around planning
um to ensure that they do deliver on on
that in
infrastructure similarly it can be
reported that following
a new ldp review strategic liaison group
meeting with essex county council team
leads
from planning highways education and
flood risk
further updates have been requested
concerning education and highways
infrastructure payments
and we're developing a more proactive
approach for sharing information between
the authorities
including more regular updates on the
essex county council spending delivery
of projects within their remit
um that uses the the money collected um
from molden
section 106. the report also
sets out the the key payments made
outwards referred to as disbursements
and they're shown in appendix one which
also includes details on the collection
of rams funding to help the county-wide
partnership
of which moderns apart
and that's for um mitigating the impact
of development in
in in terms of coastal habitats
finally in a move for more transparency
the council has now published the
section 106 monitoring spreadsheets
online
and this should support reducing the
inquiries we get through freedom of
information requests and help broaden
the understanding of what's been secured
from developments in the district
and when it is due to be paid thank you
chairman
thank you i go to the recommendations
the recommendations are
little one that members review the
information in his report
and at appendix one and that members
confirm that they are assured that the
s-106
is being managed effectively can i have
a second
of those recommendations i'm happy to
take the recommendations chairman
thank you do i have any members
questions
on the s106
councillor paul
and thank you um we um with this
on page 69 it was saying the council is
holding the following sums for
expenditure
um we we started through the wellness
group a small club we averaged
with youngsters and families about 30.
we applied for a grant
but um for some reason we
we didn't get it but um the way it was
we weren't you know offered it i i felt
it you know it was a bit unfair because
other groups like ours would start off
we average as i said 30 young people
at a time and this has been going on
since april
and i just wondered um if they could
make it more
so hands-on so people got to know what
was happening
because um groups like this would be
ideal to get people out
in to the community especially with the
obesity
and people being sectioned and
i just wondered if anything you know if
the money was still there
um is that from the s106 money
i'm not sure where the money it was just
through a wellness group i think
can i get you to email that question to
mr dobson and then mr dobson mr leslie
can get back to you
yep on that one thank you
councillor fleming you've got your hand
up
thank you chair i just wanted to ask how
long
the 369 895.51
and that amount has been held by the
council
for various health projects
mr lesley
sorry i don't have that information to
hand but happy to have a look and
circulate it
mr dobson turn your mic off
sorry no i don't have that detail to
hand but happy time we can answer
any detailed technical questions outside
of the meeting
okay councillor fleming thank you chad
i'm just going to make a wider point
here that
uh you know you only have to
speak to residents in malden you only
have to look at your social media to
know that people can't get doctor's
appointments
uh elderly people can't get through on
the phone
they're being offered triage assessments
over the internet so to be honest with
you
seeing these figures i find it quite
upsetting to be honest with you
thank you sorry chairman could i
answer on that i think i think it's
that is an issue in terms of of triage
and accuser gps is a national issue
at the moment um as a reflection of of
covid and we had some
a report on that today at the um
responsible authorities group showing
that
there has been an improvement although
there's recognition that that things
aren't improving as
as quickly as they should be
whilst some of that money has been held
for a while i don't have the figures to
hand on on how long
um you know i just wanted to
re-emphasize the work that is going on
particularly the work that's um
going on with the nhs currently to bring
forward those projects and i do
understand that there'll be a planning
application coming
forward from them in terms of ensuring
they spend that money
in the near future
so any other members questions of the
committee
no then i will move to councillor chana
thank you madam chairman i have two ones
any uh first one's very
easy i hope it might be me on the key
issues
um paragraph on page 69 it says this has
resulted in the receipt of and it gives
a figure
is that figure correct
so i read that figure and it might be my
brain cells
how i sounds read words because of some
condition i may have
it's delayed i wouldn't quite work out
if that figure should be
there as stated i think there's a comma
where there should be a decimal point
before the last two figures
yeah thank you you've answered my
question then and regarding picking up
on councillor fleming's and it is to do
with the health
projects i wanted to ask are we talking
about health
projects in terms of let's say a malden
hospital hub
or normally when we have the one or six
agreements on any planning applications
i've always seen the words
by the health authorities being used as
requirement funding which they work out
by some algorithm or formula or whatever
as for health services and i think
i have heard that perhaps and i think
this has been raised with sureland and i
think
steven whose name forgive me i forget
but i think we were hoping that we might
be able to drill down a bit to really
know perhaps where some of this funding
does go to so could that be progressed
um and i think it might mean tying up
with the health authority but i think
members do have an interest
in knowing when we do agree money is be
given to health services
is it really spent in that local area
does it apply to that or is it in the
big
wider pot and i think that's a concern
certainly a meeting i've been at with
um in relatively recent times
it's three chairman yeah i think it's a
mix of the two
to be honest there's some significant
capital infrastructure projects there's
some
that's to reduce to to broaden the
capacity of of gp
surgeries um but absolutely i mean
following on from the
the last quarterly report that we
brought to this committee there was
subsequently a seminar
to look into those those details the
the figures and the detail in a bit more
more depth
um and certainly we can provide further
information on
on exactly what that that funding
relates to
thank you that'd be very helpful madame
chairman if we could perhaps
have that greater detail i'd be very
much appreciated thank you
councillor bill thank you um i'm
interested about the
funding that's available from the
premises uh
section of nhs um south interest nearly
taught
16 years since southwester had an
increase in
its facility in respects of medical care
the existing premises are way too small
that's why people can't get the
appointment but there is a project
which seems to be thrown into the long
grass by the premises committee of nhs
and that is that thiemann's farm
southminster
it's already agreed that there will be a
large amount of housing produced there
and after that's finished there will be
a money for the sender
that medical center has never appeared
and the
national health service doesn't seem to
keep any information available through
any meetings or anything else about what
is going on in the process
further from now um in fact
it's also got a time limit on this
available after the house has been
housed have been built with this piece
of land that's been put aside
at the moment will be available for the
new premises
i don't want to think that a couple of
years go by and then the next thing i'll
say
i will down and can't do it so what is
the situation with wall district council
and the national health service
in following up this um provision that's
been made
for all this housing himself and stuff
and a
career appraisal of services available
and including what is going to be
available to
boost up those facilities with this new
center
mr dobson thank you chairman
um yes cancer bill i know i know this is
a this is a question you've asked
previously and and looked for for
delivery of
of this um as i just alluded to we've
been in recent discussions with the nhs
and i do understand that this is within
the
the business case planning process for
them now
and they are looking to bring forward
this
um i can i can give you more detail
um in the next week or so as i get
clarity
on that but but i think it's good news
that that project is progressing and um
reflects the work that we've been doing
recently and the increase in their
capacity to deliver
and that project is one that's certainly
on their radar to understand it needs to
be delivered
it's very important
i think mr dobson can pretend that
yes certainly thank you very much thank
you
can i just so much i think the density
counts i'd be interested i would because
the number of people in the villages i
represent do actually use that area
southminster at the moment
not everyone goes to burnham or
tillingham so i think it's
something that has be of uniform
universal information and importance and
knowledge to
the dengue councillors thank you
councillor edwards thank you madam
chairman um i'd just like to refer to
item three-point paragraph 3.2 can
can we be assured that some sort of
management of payments of
s106 agreements from developers uh
i i see that it's being restructured the
timing of these payments
to make sure that they don't fall behind
or developers
purposely not finishing part phasing of
the developments i know
106 payments are phased
but is that money can we be assured that
it's going to be managed in a way that
we do get that money from developers
thank you
thank you chairman yes that that work is
being done to ensure those those
payments are made and that's part of the
the um you know i um mentioned in my
introduction that there
there's going to be a bit of a um site
visit blitz
over there the the start of july to
check exactly where people are
with with their delivery and to check
that the
the payments do reflect the the progress
being made on site
thank you there's no other questions we
have had the recommendations they have
been seconded
are members happy to agree those
lovely we move on to item 12 which is
appointments of representatives on the
liaison committee
panels these are found on pages 73-74
and i call on mr dobson to present the
report
thank you chairman um this is a
straightforward
report highlighting those um those
bodies on which
this committee appoints um members
and the um the um
the current representatives are shown
and the
the number of representatives required
are shown in in the third column
the modern citizens advice bureau
liaison committee
was councillor jarvis councillor keys
and councillor shawnee councillor jarvis
would like to stay on that committee so
i would
propose that do i have
two other members to go on to that
committee
i need to have two members to go on to
that committee councillor
stevens you'd like to go on and
councillor fleming
lovely the malden district
museum liaison committee at the moment
is councillor
hull and councillor keys from the chair
i'd like to propose
counsellor nun and councillor stevens
do i have a secondary for that thank you
the parish clerk's forum is the chair of
the committee and the river crouch
coastal community team
is also the chair of the committee and
the vice chair
those are the um positions
so the council committee appoints
representatives for the outstanding
bodies detailed below for the municipal
year for may 2022
do i have a second after that i have a
second recommendation
thank you and is everybody
happy to agree that thank you
with that um i'd like to close this
meeting thank you members for
contributions this evening
i'd draw the meeting to a close at 909
908 the meet as the meeting is now
closed members are advised not to enter
into any further discussion please leave
the
meeting promptly keeping in mind social
distance requirements thank you very
much
for your time thank you officers and
thank you